[Applaudissements]
ils sont dans la rue depuis maintenant
six jours pour obtenir un meilleur
salaire et aussi pour kotawa
reconnaissent leurs droits aux
télétravail Janis Irlande a mis sa fille
manifester avec elle quand je travaille
à la maison j'ai plus de temps avec ma
famille des fois je suis plus productive
à la maison parce que au bureau il y a
des gens qui parlent fort ou qui demande
des questions qui veut jaser mais le
Conseil du Trésor soutient que
l'expérience du travail en personne est
importante et oblige maintenant ces
fonctionnaires à travailler au bureau au
moins deux ou trois jours par semaine
on veut la flexibilité pour ceux qui
veulent faire du télétravail on veut
avoir le choix si on veut faire du
template temps partiel parce qu'on sait
que la famille c'est important aussi les
fonctionnaires veulent aussi que le
droit au télétravail soit inscrit dans
leur prochaine conventions collective
pour l'instant l'employeur refuse de
l'inclure dans la convention collective
on veut que ça soit fait comme ça ouais
si c'est pas écrit il peut dire demain
ok il faut retourner
en plein au bureau sans donner une
raison ça demandait si c'est bon pour
nous inscrire ce droit dans une
convention collective constituerait un
important précédent au pays selon cette
avocate dans les convention collectives
effectivement c'est très rare très rare
et c'est toujours très rare de voir des
dispositions sur le télétravail il faut
dire qu'avant la pandémie le télétravail
était peu répandu selon une étude de
l'Université de Montréal seulement 13%
des employés nord-américaine le
pratiquaient en 2018 était surtout
gérer de façon individuelle donc au cas
par cas en le faisant de façon
collective et là on met tout le monde
dans le même bateau et c'est là que
c'est difficile d'évaluer est-ce que
dans tous les secteurs d'organisation de
la fonction publique est-ce qu'on peut
garder la performance qu'on s'attend là
de la part des fonctionnaires pédéraux
je pense que le conflit dure pas
longtemps Jacques Letourneau a été
président de la CSN le télétravail est
là pour rester dit-il
Ottawa doit en tenir compte on a intérêt
effectivement à l'inscrire dans des
conventions collectives pour être au
clair sur comment ça fonctionne
l'inclure dans une convention c'est pas
synonyme de rigidité faut faire bien
attention le télétravail faut
l'expérimenter donc ça peut être une
lettre d'entente ça peut être en
fonction de chaque ministère selon lui
le revenu pour les employeurs de
réinventer l'organisation du travail
d'autres évolutions dans le monde du
travail le travail autonome la
révolution informatique technologique
puis on vit avec alors je suis convaincu
que moyen de trouver un chemin pour
négocier
la vision est différente chez bien des
acteurs du secteur privé la Chambre de
commerce de Montréal sans éliminer
complètement le travail hybride vient de
demander à tous ces employés de revenir
au bureau à partir du 1er mai la place
normale de travail le lieu normal de
travers nos employés sera la place
d'affaires qui est nos bureaux nous on
le fait mais les acteurs du secteur
privé qui le font c'est pour un constat
bien simple c'est qu'il y a une baisse
d'efficacité du travail de groupe une
baisse de productivité de groupe dans
les organisations Michel Leblanc espère
kotawa arrivera à la même conclusion
sachant que ce qui se négocie au public
a souvent influence sur les conditions
de travail au privé que quelqu'un
arriverait en disant non mais moi je
veux un principe de télétravail
obligatoire ou en tout cas comme
respecte le gérant le propriétaire va
dire ben voyons donc c'est pas comme ça
que je m'organise ce qui est débattu au
milieu de cette grève dépasse donc
largement le futur quotidien des
fonctionnaires difficile encore de dire
qu'elle est importante
Ottawa donnera au télétravail mais pour
l'instant les négociations sont dans
l'impasse ici jean-Sébastien Cloutier
Radio-Canada Montréal